you
professor Peter Doherty very welcome to
this in to you thank you what made you
interested in science oh I wasn't all
that interested in science as a kid I
was good at it at school and then I was
looking for what to do at university I'd
never studied biology and I went to an
open day at the local veterinary school
thinking I'd like to do something in
disease research or something like that
but didn't want to be a medical doctor
because I don't like sick people very
much and want to be around them because
they were always complaining and was
fascinated by what they did in the
veterinary school and also by the fact
that it was summer in Australia which is
very hot and there was a very cute 20
year old laboratory technician
demonstrating she had on a white coat
and I think not very much else and I
thought this looked very interesting
because I was 16 years old and totally
immature and wanting to grow up quickly